welcome DJ hey buddy it's hard to get
you in and the more I know you don't
like to get up I don't blame you it's
yeah we weren't we weren't so late you
know yeah I remember when you started
doing oh and eight years ago and that
was the switch that was almost the first
switch from the back table of everyone
being out till like 3:00 in the morning
just talking [ __ ] at the back table the
seller was what you got to get here you
had to start doing the earlier shows mm
shocked Oboro for because before that it
was it was an afternoon show so it was
okay to go home at like [ __ ] 5:00 in
the morning it didn't matter
yeah but then once it went some mornings
I was it yeah I remember that schedule
switch a lot that's when it started
that's when that back table started
breaking down a little bit yeah cause it
just wasn't there was one less person
and then somebody else gets something
and then there's two less people we were
talking to knew where the glue that held
everybody well you know just welcome we
was almost Angus tankfest and I didn't
realize every fear was stealing all your
announcements you know a fierce gang
fest a fear fest yeah I love it yeah
yeah he's uh he's snagging every single
announcement from Lois which is driving
Lois night it's gotta be why does why
does the Lois just keep it quiet then
why is he telling him I'm not sure how
we're not even quite sure how he's
finding out also I think always just
announcing people that he wants as if
they're already there so who do you have
booked I know I'm doing it and who else
according Ari Shaffir Steve Rosie's got
something involved Ari okay I'm not sure
even with the other ones that are fully
announced yet but I mean it's gonna be
an amazing they got the new location at
Brooklyn Bazaar so we could go from okay
having only 300 tickets available to now
a thousand tickets we can do so we've
always nice we ought we sold out on
presale I think in 48 hours and then on
may 5th the official tickets go on sale
so we're hoping hoping it's something
good oh that's great third year so what
is it now it's just a bunch of
colleagues doing different shows at the
same time or different times well this
room we have ability to have two big
shows going on at once
okay and if you have everybody kind of
perform twice every won't get to see
everything but this movie that we've did
it historically adzick from noon on we
have like pot live podcasts and and then
at night time is when it ramps up I mean
historically we've had the naked comedy
the naked a roast battle is one of the
most intense things I've ever seen I
suggest you hang in
therefore it make it vote that's a great
idea I mean a Allyson clump last year
pulled her jokes out of her [ __ ]
she had a plastic bag and she took it
out of her snatch and [ __ ] it was one of
the funniest things I've ever seen did
people laugh oh yeah let's see yeah the
other girl had a I mean an extraordinary
long tampon string hanging out zac amico
cut himself wrestling style like sliced
himself open and then re she waited yeah
and then Ari Shaffir took a piss in a
cup on stage and threw it on Zach so fun
like that so if you can open if you
haven't got your tickets everybody send
an Ari Shaffir spits go into Zach's open
wound
I'd have to assume it made its way in
there so no that's exact upset you know
what's funny if it was me it's funny how
your friends know what your limit is I
guess if that was I don't think Ari
would have done that to me cuz if any
friend would have done that to me I
would have hit them and then immediately
bent over but like you doubt when you
head you have to punch somebody
you threw piss oh yeah in public and you
missed my mouth this is Clint I don't
know why people think is yes Clinton
Illinois what's up hey Jimmy yes I think
and I want to say hi to everybody
crackle crackle I heard it's probably
and want to say Bennington and you never
know when he's screwing with people but
I remember him several years ago making
the comment he was talking about both of
you guys and then all of a sudden he
said I don't know why there can't be too
heavy metal comments and it was just
kind of a sigh but like it was like it
was a dig and I always wondered I'm like
well Jays not been on the show much he
never shows up on the skank view and I
just started wondering if that was just
a Ronnie beef thing or if there was
really some kind of rift between you
guys Jim used to always talk about it on
the show actually we do a lot of it off
air that he felt like Jay was taking his
throne as the king of heavy metals yeah
I mean that was my thing the king of
heavy metal
yeah can I do a lot of metal talk in my
accent exactly right thanks that's great
that neither of us do that
I mean since let me died I mean that
it's an open air now like it but but no
there's no rifts I don't know why people
I wanted you on the show and it's hard
to get you on because I'm taking it
you're just up until three o'clock of
the moisture sure yeah it is uh it's I
find that very bizarre that that
narrative has been created but just get
along never has any problem of course we
pushed it whatever J wouldn't show up
everything like I said if it were if it
was like loo even if it was Dave Kim one
time I was coming I could write man yeah
and I think they came in another time
but it was just them book like they're
running a comedy tour or something and I
definitely pushed forward the Jay said
he did not want to come up B he wouldn't
come and he'll come in that studio yeah
well I want to come in ya know I'm not
confused as to why people you read on
that you were in on that day with you
were here when Ace Frehley came in you
were here when Patrice hilarious my two
appearances ever on ona were so I got
completely usurped by what was happening
Ace Frehley happened to come in it
wasn't like a booking with the birthday
cake he was here yeah he was here in the
building that got him to come in so I
remember I ended up I sat here for a
minute and they were like do you need to
kind of sit over there with a microphone
I already didn't I forget who else was
here but it was enough people that like
there was a man always Anthony Anthony
who decided to give a freely precedence
over you who would have put a Celia by
probably the world well yeah it was my
birthday and he brought in a cake with
an ass with a log of [ __ ] sticking out
of it and right and I bit the [ __ ] log
out of the cake I mean it had to happen
you did yeah and then when Patrice was
here with Bobo at the up-and-down get up
and down game yeah that was that that
was a great moment to be a part of isn't
it weird you look back like I watched
that moment and I in the moment it's
just your dumb friend is laughing but
you don't realize like this is going to
be one of the definitive things I
remember about this person for the rest
of my life it's crazy like you don't
realize it in that moment it is it
really isn't sale people it's it's a
millions of YouTube hits people [ __ ]
absolutely love it
I just wanted to go back to that he gave
you why do you think you wanted this
[ __ ] with the thing do you notoriously I
know the pissed thing
silly I guess I just to be a you know
plus chocolates delicious yes I'm
guessing that's why they did that I was
just looking for a friend I was just
casting a rope there for a friend in the
world I've gotten weirdly into watching
now hot girl [ __ ] porn have you I've
seen it but not not in a masturbation -
no I shouldn't say that I should not in
a finishing masturbation yeah I own but
I've definitely been coming Triggs by I
don't know why what are they [ __ ] on
is the Brazilian stuff where they're
[ __ ] on each other or is it ones
where they're just dropping logs on the
floor the floor ones don't matter but
very specifically the American I'm
always just blown away that a a pretty
nineteen twenty year old girl is going
to just [ __ ] like a like someone was
able to pay her enough money I guess
because I didn't I wasn't very good
getting laid at all through my teens
early 20s even probably like the late
20s with that stuff that I'm intrigued
that I was nervous to ask a girl that I
thought was pretty if she wanted to hang
out or do something and yet somebody was
like hey I'm a three or four hundred
bucks take a [ __ ] it is incredible the
balls that these people have to ask
these women to do something and the fact
that they do it yeah that's right that's
what gets me like a beautiful girl
showing her face like I'm getting ready
to [ __ ] on camera and never have a job
in the media like what do you do after
this like what what is it you do where
you you take a dump on camera and then
like what was your goal when it started
and what does it become after that's a
great point have you seen the Netflix
documentary about the guys who get the I
don't hear what it's called it's the
girls that get into porn oh the yeah
yeah that really made me uh that
actually turned me off more to the
quote-unquote amateur porn yeah because
it does look like a just a draining they
make them all I kind of live in a
dormitory situation with things going on
with weird connect tattoo Russian guys
watching all the time you think it's a
little bit it's a little bit nicer with
the [ __ ] porn people I wonder if that's
more voluntary I don't know I don't
think [ __ ] porn revolves you haven't
live in a dormitory for yeah it was
always free
as a Stacey in there oh she's probably
just peeing or doing her maid do not
waste
do not waste that beautiful [ __ ] look
yeah there is something there is
something amazing about an American I
don't know why I'm a because I always
like the language like when you can
communicate with somebody it turns me on
more sure and they can tell me but we
also know how much opportunity there is
here theoretically in America to do
other things that aren't [ __ ] on
camera so the fact that that's the
choice that would be made is the
intriguing thing no that's the amazing
joy though that is the opportunity my
god I can pay my rent [ __ ] on camera
that's phenomenal what if I brought it
up on stage and Cleveland and there was
the steamer there I asked I told a girl
in the audience but pretty younger girls
but and I was like you have a price what
would be the price honestly to to just
[ __ ] on camera you don't do anything
sexual with anybody you said it be fully
naked they show your face then you take
a hot [ __ ] on camera and you know the
young girl of course always I mean that
would have to start it like 50 million
dollars and then someone else goes I bet
she'd do it for 1 million dollars and
then of course a realistic pretty
30-something you're all went thousand I
want to probably get that up and she
goes I go just a thousand Han she goes I
mean I'm [ __ ] anyway which is we
just gotta find that personality in the
world I guess it's got that attitude
about it
but guys they never come without damage
I doubt it I doubt if you [ __ ] on camera
by the way I don't think if you [ __ ] on
camera for someone's personal catalog it
seems way less if something [ __ ] off
course there's gonna be a dot-com you
know watermark at the bottom seems like
yeah you're putting that out there in
the world like [ __ ] everybody you're
doing it for someone personally it's
different cuz it's private and it's a
dirty thing but it seemed yeah if you
are doing it on camera going up this is
out there you guys want to ask you to
cuz you and Dan do a bonfire and I heard
you're a thing with yamaneika with piano
we hope that morning yeah and you know
Doug's always a little whatever he comes
in he was a little so it's a little bit
of the night before bleeding here but by
the time you guys got it I mean he was
also
literally drinking travel sized bottle
of liquor bottle liquor as you city bit
tipsy he gave me the warning when I said
because I just found he was in town so I
was like hey come on in and and do the
show if he was like yeah sure he goes
but I warn you I'm cruise ship drunk and
he came in and he in fact was I said it
was funny it's amazing how sick of Fanta
cos fans get sometimes because so many
of them started tweeting at me on social
media like you didn't defend Doug enough
you lost a fan today wow you put your
you know you bet on the wrong horse you
piece of [ __ ] people get so angry I
thought doesn't need defending dunking
handle himself
he didn't need defending at all and uh I
don't think y'all man echidna so I need
you defending what happened it was a no
look I'm new enough at especially
running a radio show that I didn't
really quite know how to chop you know
was very uncomfortable even though I
knew if something happened cuz Sodor
said on the way up when we had Doug
coming in because you know yamaneika is
coming in today too I go yeah you think
they're gonna get along and I said I
they should like we're gonna be talking
about we have topics to talk to them
about so maybe they'll disagree on that
stuff I never quite saw it just going
the way it went but I did tell soda I'm
like if not you know great radio I guess
it is interesting when when people are
getting into it it's like it's hard to
step in because it's like I know it's
fun to listen to it's at exactly yeah
you know you had the awkwardness where I
was saying before with Dave Landau and
Kevin Brennan and Kevin Brennan I mean
what do you do we literally booked the
awkwardness though I mean like we know
exactly what I mean to not thinking it's
gonna get into I mean you see nobody and
you'll either of you think someone's
gonna stand up at one point yeah and
that you can't have just because then
you know then they won't be allowed to
building and I love Kevin so I don't
want to see him getting you know he's
great when it starts to drift towards
assault okay let's let's pull the line
here cuz that yeah that'll go very very
bad but yamaneika I mean I just people
got angry that I said I just understand
her point I think she maybe I could have
went differently or what was her point I
didn't hear you say that
her point I understand where she was
coming from was that soon as as soon as
she walked in Doug just makes it her
first stepping into the room Doug goes
oh great because another black person's
in the room bingo gets nervous then by
chance bingo was simply just she was
sitting at the console with us she
simply moved so Yaman he could sit down
right like sushi but it seemed like so
when she see says that and then bingo
moves so she could sit and then also
when bingo moves our producer Jacob
moves over to that seat so it didn't
even read that she was actually getting
up to let her sit down right oh she's
just walk it just looks like she was
uncomfortable with a black person okay
then within two minutes after that Doug
as the Amin ich if she's really a woman
because he's been fooled before so now
he's called her a man he's also as we
previously established cruise ship drunk
cruise ship drunk so it's slurry it's
hilarious to us and dominique is not
quite sure what to make of it and then
he he goes which is hilarious he tries
to introduce us I believe that everyone
kind of agrees that he was introducing a
pretty interesting subject of what she
would have needed to ask a girl which
could have been Christine or yamaneika
but yamaneika is right across from him
and he's gonna ask has a man ever
regretted having sex with you the next
morning I guess didn't really she's
getting into the meets who think we
having a guy who feels that way because
has anyone ever regretted having sex
with you the next morning and yamaneika
skeptically he goes no no one's ever
regretted [ __ ] me the next morning
and then Stanhope says exactly like this
he goes well then you are unaware so now
in her mind I understand for the fourth
time now on the day she's been called
fat and ugly by this guy okay and I
think she just went on and started now
here's the thing she started tearing
into it and did say funny things she was
wearing a mr. Furley suit I think made
fun of someone saying
bingos probably regrets [ __ ] him
every day and they went back and forth
and it just got awkward and heated and
then the funniest part to me is you
could hear me and Dan both scary ah just
going like oh come on game show host
voice come on
Detroit gun cakes bit on the television
before and and Doug walked out his last
words were hilariously goes big Jay fix
this and then he went into default she
and I talked right afterwards and he's
fine and he was thanking us for being on
the show and it was it was great radio
okay
uh yeah mineka she came back on the show
the next day and was uh seemed fine with
it but I heard that she did end up going
on like Tuesdays with stories and
getting like a little teary and bummed
out because tears well I get you know
she probably should have said that cuz I
think it just opens up the floodgates
sometimes but you know yamaneika is a
tough chick but I understand as much as
anybody when you have a couple every day
there's something negative on social
media yeah of course but usually
bookended by like love the show this was
hilarious blah blah blah and that's like
you [ __ ] suck you know that's
whatever yeah yeah but that all rains
down but for a couple days myself
included you're gonna get it's just the
people stirring up their dead and it
very best you get people like half
defending you don't want to get they
don't want to thrown them either it goes
look it wasn't the best thing he could
have done but he did what he could I
suppose it's like the best defense
you're gonna get and everybody else just
goes so I think it probably God so we're
after oh they couldn't have went more
racist and surprised aggressively I'm
surprised that's weird yeah I want to
Twitter when your picture is a picture
of an egg yeah you do get that like when
you're on the [ __ ] end of it for
whatever reason you said something like
are you do it's a movie or you
approached Trump against whatever the
[ __ ] you said some and they just it's
just one of those things they're all
looking at you like get them yeah yeah
and you're in the barrel for a few days
it is what it is and then it just it
really does just go it all goes with
it's finally this picture hawkgirl's
wanted up here that's the guy that's the
guy who has the house sank with all
those girls just lived there why when
they were all done cuz they they get to
live there for free technically but yeah
but he controls their money so that's
the amateur porn thing yeah well the
girl who ended up quitting at the end of
it and going back to her boyfriend quit
cuz she said I was here for
was like eight months or something and
she cleared she only made 25 grand and
spent you know most of that cuz she had
to while she was out there living in
Miami in that world so it is create I
think that's to for me why I've never
been a strip club guy as an adult or
even a hookers guy as much as because
working where I used to drive strippers
and escorts to bachelor parties and
stuff and I'd that job when I was right
there you just when you're on the ride
home
but that's why I'm surprised this guy
like loves this job so much having these
girls Dana's house you see the sadness
of it you get the story if you're in a
car car ride with a stripper who just
you know had guys bite twenties out of
her snatch for an hour that's when you
start getting like that well I'm just
trying to get my kids back from social
services Oh justify yeah those seven
guys who [ __ ] me like they were a
little mean and rough you know
everything you're just like yeah you see
the human side yeah it just makes you
feel like oh they're not into this huh
yeah this girl didn't want to [ __ ] to
fit 14 random strangers so yeah anymore
no I was going is like if I get like the
goof of going if you're going with a
group of guys to kind of like have a
laugh or whatever but like to go and
really have any live on what I've never
felt the confidence that I could polish
stripper ever never I've only seen one
person ever do it weirdly Dave Attell
some insane makes it when I went on the
insomniac tour with him in Philly he
liked this girl the girl wanted to leave
the boss that he could leave with her it
was pretty hilarious wow she laughs yeah
and she was so hot yeah it was crazy but
I've never even with SD our show that we
do what you've done before
Jim is uh we have porn stars are all the
time they make a lot of I'm gonna come
[ __ ] you and Christine tonight promises
oh god yeah and then nothing nothing we
just had a Ralph Sutton on chip podcast
yeah like Ralph you know it's hilarious
to with that is they they say they're
gonna do that
they say they're like oh yeah let's get
out of here I think we would have hooked
up with some of these porn stars had I
had more self-confidence because what I
always do I rarely do Monday nights at
the stand anymore they have that frantic
show they just kind of runs and if I pop
in I can go on and I don't ever do it
just cuz my schedule right but any time
a stripper or
a porn star yeah I'll hang out with you
and Christine after the shows hanging
out I'll go back to your place I'm still
like well I gotta go to this I wanted to
see me do comedy first oh no he's
[ __ ] me for like the stunts I wanted
to feel like oh this guy does have some
want to validate yourself in her eyes
like wow this guy's the [ __ ] and Ralph's
point out he goes I've lost probably
eight of them just from because by the
time they get we're done the stand there
like hammered and then we're like me and
Christine gonna be like I guess we're
gonna put you in a cab you know your
nose is running yes home going out for a
drink and then taking her home can't
yeah I have to live I have to believe in
my mind there's some reason like now
this girl wants to [ __ ] right what was
the big Jimmy get jealous and threesomes
like you do it just you her and a girl
and is there any does she ever get
jealous or any uncomfortable moments
never in the actual [ __ ] part of it
but sure yeah afterwards if it what's
got what's gone wrong after it's that
fine line of you know we fought there's
a couple that we hook up with regularly
you know a couple of girls are a regular
it's not easy to find new ones all the
time but in the few regularly its to be
how many times do I ask is a big deal oh
if you're pushing it you know I'm huh
even worse if I if I do hey let's uh
maybe this week we'll hook up with a
chick or something if it gets specific
like hey why don't we call that one I
think that or if it's like I've had the
communication Oh which happens and she's
usually not a big deal but it's just
like if I have specifics you know well
you know she's working that night till
3:00 a.m. so we can't that night but
Thursday she's free and clear
but she's visiting her parents on said
no this yeah guy we did go back and
forth probably too much yeah you got a
uh do you don't like it like she could
just look at your phone the conversation
if she wants to uh she could I don't
ever go through her sigh I hate that so
much I'm so I'm skittish about anyone
holding my foot Lewis points it out all
the time Lucia Gomez if I'm showing I'm
like you know a video or something or a
YouTube video and he puts his hands on
my phone I gripped my phone even harder
yeah I don't know why I'm just you know
what it is I got caught cheating so bad
in 2000 it was like maybe 2006
sir seven so bad and it was just [ __ ]
going through I used to put my I used to
put my phone at night with Max wife I
used to turn it off and put it my
pillowcase is how much I really just
wanted it not see and why and my ex-wife
even know I put it my pillowcase I
forget what a reason I gave was like
yeah I still want to be Bali you know I
need to sleep in the morning I don't
want this yeah bother I'm putting it in
my pillowcase so I'm putting a penalty
make sense yeah of course and and then
one day I was seeing another girl and I
had put that night mean the other girl
had had an argument because what she did
was I was showing her something in my
phone and she happened to see that her
name and my phone was a Jason I think it
was under Jason Steinberg are all
manager that's how little he actually
called me I was more of an Evan star and
I hadn't she was like why would you have
my name in there like that
you know if I'm your girlfriend right
and I was I forget whatever [ __ ]
excuse I gave it she half bought but we
argued pretty big about it and then as
like a thing I'm like what do you think
I'm hiding this is so rude I don't know
we think I'm hiding a go look up and I
put it in as her first name my last name
like just to be like almost like funny
about it and went to bed that night
pretty like she was texting me still you
know we're going back and forth and I
put the phone I think I put it in though
I have whatever was I just kind of
passed out and didn't think about my
phone and in the morning she started
calling a bunch and my ex-wife just
answered the phone and they had an hour
and a half phone call before I was still
asleep
oh just no visions of sugarplums when
your phone rings her name comes up with
your last yes
I'm wondering like Oh some cousin I've
never met yeah and they get on the phone
and they talked for an hour and a half
and then she woke me up with a she was
in law school time with the law book to
the face and then it was just
Hostel and all forward them oh and I got
what point that's a terrible thing
because you know how long did you try
the life or when you got caught like you
first wake up how long do you try to
like no she's lying I didn't even get to
that it was just too it was too deep at
that point but I did do way longer than
I was confused about what was going on
played the confused oh you said there
she goes and this girl
you know Lauren blah blah blah blah and
she's good and I just kept going wait
what you don't know what I'm talking
about you know I did I grabbed someone
else's phone say they finally realize
I'm completely busted oh yeah I got
kicked in the nuts by both of them as
separate occasions did the other girls
you look like the other girl again no
she was done yet no no I went over there
one time just kind of like be apologetic
cuz again it's one of those things when
you're living it you don't realize how
[ __ ] up here yeah yeah at all and then
when it's pointed out like everyone is
just sad around you my daughter was a
pretty young baby still I just [ __ ]
that I'm like what's my life gonna do
then I had to go to South Africa for
three weeks like four days later which
ended up being for the best yeah cuz you
get away from the world and that's when
the story I just told on Ari Shaffir is
uh this is that happening the last
season I just told the story of that
girl the side girl took a naked picture
she had a me that I forgot that was like
a joke picture even because I there's
never been a picture be naked where I'd
be like this is good yeah yourself to
this it was a [ __ ] joke and then she
put it on Craigslist while I was in
South Africa for the men looking for me
which was pretty great Wayne Rana is the
guy a person who found it in an actual
like you know Craigslist's
yeah wait you know Wayne he used to
write oh yeah yeah and yeah he
absolutely uh he found it and gave me
the heads up and then he told everybody
to Patrice included to flag it because
this was not something that I wanted up
there uh-huh
and Patrice made that his a screen saver
yeah there are thanksgiving one time he
told me to push the mouse on his
computer
he just laughs every 15 minutes that's
really funny yeah so she's all right so
you got busted and you it's undeniable
at that point sometimes when you're so
quiet it's almost a relief to be so 100%
caught because you realize I don't have
to think of a lot like as Brock when
somebody else has given all the details
so you're not even responsible for
painting this picture yeah you just got
a lot of sabi head nods and did you
really blah blah blah with this girl you
go I'm sorry yeah and it helped yes I
mean I wonder sometimes if that's even a
decent argument like I don't know
because it seems to put that stress on
your shoulders just seems very very
bizarre what was funny was I was
starting to get out of that chick anyway
I was very into her I believe it's
because you know get in fact guy my
whole life she was like a really skinny
girl oh pretty and I was very excited
that she seems so into [ __ ] me and
then I remember I was with Patrice on
the road somewhere and I wanted to brag
to him about how you know there's pretty
girls he's like let me see and I had a
picture of her the same day I took that
she took to take a picture of me I had a
picture of her she just opened her towel
and she was really thin yeah a really
thin chick with like very small tits and
I opened up he just goes that [ __ ]
looks like Buffalo Bob from it looks
like the [ __ ] like the picture almost
changed for me when he said it is you're
right this isn't sexy this looks like a
boy damn it
the funny part too is what a piece of
[ __ ] thing to say to a guy who's showing
you a girl I try to go hey Patrice
you're a big guy too aren't you proud of
me you do look good by the way you look
like you've dropped a lot of weight I'm
trying man I got to I'm doing a Netflix
half-hour they're doing dirty half hours
oh nice
in June 30 there's the half hours but
they're doing like around
that are like oh don't like dirty dirty
comedy so I'm doing that and I have two
months so I'm doing some just a goofy
diet oh good yeah it's it's essentially
brown rice grilled chicken and
vegetables daytime and then fish and
vegetables at night no dairy no we're at
me yeah as you like it
eating like that yeah I like the
benefits of it aside from dropping
weight at all I like not it's amazing
how every time I eat I eat until it
hurts sort of here yeah even if it's not
unhealthy food it just gotta eat so go
so I do kind of like not I've never been
able to eat between shows on the road
before and now I can cuz doesn't feel
like I ate when I'm done yeah a piece of
salmon and broccoli doesn't lay heavy
when you're not on stage like you know a
t-bone steak and smashed potatoes or hey
what happened here are you happy to you
I'd loved your crowd work show it was
like it was original and it was fine and
you're great at it and why did that all
of a sudden they did the network guy so
Seto okay see someone under so we're
shopping and around with Comedy Central
in a couple other places hoping that it
gets picked up again cuz it was so fun
yeah it's great to get comics to do it
and no one feels they're burning
material yeah it's easily accomplished
to do something with or I'll just go and
[ __ ] around and it's way it's not
they're gonna edit the 12 minutes down
to the best five right it was yeah was
going great and then that whole network
just ate [ __ ] what happened to them did
they just they go away we own the name
and their fur sale so wherever it goes I
I think they'd like to try to hopefully
buy the catalog too so you can they're
the ones we already have
doesn't that suck tell like you get
something and people like it and then
there's beyond your control the network
or the the site it just they a financial
problems isn't [ __ ] you can do about it
it really well everyone tries to now get
their own it's crazy any subscription
things you have to get if you want yeah
six CBS has a subscription so Netflix -
I saw a trailer today for a show that's
coming out on CBS only like their
streaming service which is bizarre
well the network's all know they're
going away sooner or later they all know
that eventually they're gonna go away
maybe not now but in 20 years so they're
trying to do Sears yeah I think I'll be
are I mean network TV maybe you're right
because there is still something about
the middle of the country still exists
it down at eight o'clock with commercial
and everything and just watch the
traffic still watch his movies on cable
like TBS like he'll see a movies on on
the cable guide you'd be like oh let me
stop and watch this no surprise no but I
mean like do you do that with like if
it's only TBS or something like that
cuz that's something I can never
remember so now i te t v-- now I can do
my girlfriend does that all the time
like I'm watching Road house on TNT what
why would you wait I think I mean the
TV's got apps are that you can watch
anything you ever wanted with no
commercials right yeah the commercials
are a little annoying access at least
keeps the language in though look when
they start taking the language I would I
forget always watching and running man
on access that's whatever it's called oh
and it's one of the language is there
and then I did I butcher I just [ __ ]
fast the commercials it's mainly music
stuff right or no access yeah music
concerts and like concerts and stuff
here they show yeah was Lou Strait Gomez
crying on Legion escapes recently did I
see that on YouTube yeah why was it real
yeah cuz here II watched Milo and Otis
and again watch Milo and Otis it's that
it's a movie about a cat and a dog that
take care of each other to get somewhere
I've never watched it he seemed like he
was intoxicated and then he started
talking about it and then they heard it
a little drunk also then he started
crying but for real yeah it was
absolutely crying for it he shared this
moment with his it was a movie that made
him cry when he was a kid and then he
washed it with his son and had a tender
moment after we were talking about like
you know hooker [ __ ] or something
that's why I was it was placed weird
Milo and Otis yeah it's uh there's a fun
facts we found out though about this
it's a Japanese movie I think originally
there's no oh no because there's no
people in it there's no dialogue yeah oh
they just dumped it over but apparently
the big thing about it was why we look
into it at all was many many dogs and
cats died in the making this movie
non-stop there's a scenes where they had
them floating down the river in a box
and I think they said at least eight
cats were killed oh my god
every take they just had to get a new
cat you're the craft services out there
eating lunch at the cast fresh dig it
off
in Australia the Animal Liberation
Queensland their founder Jacqui Kent
alleged the killing of more than 20
kittens during the production and added
that she was disturbed by reports from
Europe which alleged the the other
animals had been injured as bah-bah-bah
it goes on and on but over 20 kittens a
producer broke a cat's paw to make it
appear unsteady on its feet oh my god ah
and this is Lewis is good like feel-good
movie it well it did make him sad he
probably liked the bonus features
probably the deleted scenes what was the
other given see Cannibal Holocaust no
that's a band in America they say movie
its star it's starring the guy who was
the only guy who [ __ ] Debbie and Debbie
Does Dallas remember the guy I remember
the shop owner it's not is it Harry I'm
gonna my name is the harry reems or is
it John Leslie or is it Randy West no no
we did all of them it's uh if you look
up the name of the guy like Ranger @l
interviewed him on a dave's old porn at
one point he looks like he's a creepy
looking old guy now but he's the guy who
[ __ ] debbie does dallas who is that
yeah i'd love to know
let's get his name it's amazing what a
big porn that is and it was just an
average under the name as soon as i see
it
cast it is richard balaji ball at yeah
that's what i was just always say are
bola is I think also him no or no he's a
different guy no different guy so no
he's in Cannibal Holocaust they sort of
Eli Roth remade it as the green green
inferno in Inferno but nowhere near what
this movie did but apparently in this
movie they had to go to like court to
prove they weren't murdering actually
looks it's so grisly and looks like real
tribal people even the green inferno
like it's kind of unbelievable that
movie got made now yeah you know it did
go pretty far but even in nowhere near
as far look like they like kill him in
this one they actually they do kill
several animals they like rip the shell
off of a tortoise and they killing him
when they show him like actually killing
a monkey and there's as many scenes
where it looks like I don't know how
they would have possible especially this
time they ripped the shell of a tortoise
yeah
I musta hated that don't worry gross
though worse by the way Travis what did
you say my ear there's something with
our communication I can't hear you just
say time here three minutes oh three men
okay they said woman okay yeah I've
never seen this but I will watch it oh
is that the turtle yeah and what else
could it do what a stupid question
picture no they actually take the top of
the show off I think that's also live oh
yeah yeah they do some [ __ ] up [ __ ] in
the movie for sure there's a lot there
they show him like it's like it was
banned in America for you could always
find it online but it's uh I think you
can get it on DVD it's worth a peek
do you remember blood sucking freaks no
I never said that was Troma put that out
they did always that trauma mmm yeah
like Ronny the dwarf or whatever the
blood sucking freaks that was like this
big band moving in you're watching okay
cheesy they if you're gonna do the band
in America thing it better be pretty
grisly let's see online now serbian film
should be bad I mean it's something to
watch but that should be by being thumb
it's a movie called a Serbian film I
when I sit on the road like it was so
funny how I have to watch cartoons at
night to go to sleep like not like like
you like the Bob's Burgers Family Guy
type [ __ ] yeah to fall asleep in hotel
because I'm very uncomfortable and
downright almost like scared in hotels
at night still we are 40 years old I
don't know I just am uneasy like I
usually leave a like the desk light on I
put the TV on ESPN on mute
just to have sports happening the
background I watch a car mad at all the
sign of someone who is raped as a boy
are you scared of the dark are you as
scared as an arrow I just like I'm a
part I guy I don't just go to sleep in
the dark so it's just like if I sit
there I'm almost worried about my own
thoughts like just sitting there and
thinking myself to sleep would be awful
so I'd rather kind of zone into
something and I just again I think
hotels just weirdly uncomfortable and
unsettling behaving some reason